in our series the dish this morning we
are digging into some Texas style
barbecue that comes to us via southeast
Asia Chad pong better known these days
is the Cambodian Cowboy came to Southern
California as a boy to escape the
horrors of the brutal Khmer Rouge
Communist Regime now as Carter Evans
shows us he's wowing crowds with some of
the best barbecue west of the Panhandle
with some unique Cambodian flavors
[Applause]
[Music]
right there buddy they call him the
Cambodian cowboy
this is the moment we've all been
waiting for so what do we got here oh
man we got a whole plate of goodness
tri-tip right there and our spare ribs
here is the game changer right here this
is the the Cambodian smoked pork belly
so you got ginger in there Chinese spice
spices a little teriyaki sauce a little
bit of salt a little bit of pepper that
is so good I could eat that all day long
absolutely
Chad puong is setting the barbecue scene
on fire
[Music]
in Southern California his unique take
on classic Texas barbecue with a
Cambodian twist is a huge hit at his
pop-up events in Long Beach you've
definitely got the look going on now
what's the Asian guy doing with with
some boots and a hat on like trying to
sell Barbie as a gimmick and stuff but
they didn't really understand my story
Huang was just seven years old when he
arrived in California in 1980 as a
refugee I remember vividly every every
every stuff that happened we had to walk
through landmines to sniper fire even
sleeping in the jungle just to make it
to the Thai Cambodian border for help
his father was murdered by the feared
Khmer Rouge regime and his family left
everything behind except their culinary
Traditions
Huang fell in love with barbecue after
he and his stepfather moved to Texas
where the weekends are spent at the
smoker and drinking beers in the yard
gonna trim the fat he learned to butcher
at a Beef Processing facility near
Amarillo let's bring you back to your
days at the meat packing plant but
Family Ties eventually brought him back
to Long Beach the biggest Cambodian
Community outside of the country itself
a job loss during the pandemic turned
out to be a blessing in disguise
Huang poured his savings into a rolling
smoker and turned his passion into a
profession I know one thing about people
in Texas is they'd love their barbecue
and they take it very seriously oh yeah
definitely man so when you started
adding these Asian spices to it how are
people reacting they were kind of
skeptical
after all no one knew what tuacco
sausage was the Cambodian delicacy
stuffed with beef pork and fermented
rice
that's right yeah go ahead but after the
first bite it all makes sense oh my God
that is so good it's that little
sourness in the middle yeah and that
comes from the fermentation of the rice
it's now one of his most popular dishes
and has earned him a loyal following
it does look amazing people line up to
get his barbecue before he sells out how
far did you drive for this food today an
hour and 20 minutes from my house worth
it yes
the Cambodian Cowboy now pops up at Long
Beach breweries every week got your
brisket your beef ribs and how is
business oh man it's going great I mean
man there's like so many so many people
are so you know accepted of the flavors
that I bring and then they're they're
blown away that one was good
the flavors meld in the smoker his
brisket with Cambodian pepper cooks for
17 hours
I give 110 wherever I go no slacking
once I laced my boots and put on my hat
and start cutting the meat so that's
that's where it begins yeah
finally like found that Niche that
really makes me happy that makes a lot
of people happy I couldn't wait
Huang eventually plans to have a
restaurant without wheels but for now
I'm gonna continue doing my pop-up just
being out there and just you know riding
to the next one like a cowboy right a
Cambodian Cowboy yeah yeah for CBS
mornings I'm Carter Evans Long Beach
California
Tony if I could lick the screen
gracefully I would do that I like it
what he said a whole plate of goodness
on there God if we hop in the car now
we'll be on the west coast in 18 hours
somebody's going to back him in a
restaurant I guarantee that looks great
thank you thank you